У старовинному Храмі Живописного Джерела у Києві на Борщагівці
отець Даниїл служить вже 6 років.
У минулому, як всі священики Київського патріархату,
він молився за єдність православ’я в Україні.
Тепер просить, аби настало порозуміння між почесним патріархом Філаретом
та очільником єдиної Православної Церкви України митрополитом Епіфанієм.
Українська православна церква, як і Українська Автокефальна церква
і представники Московського патріархату, що вони підписали документ,
який засвідчує, що дані структури припиняють свою діяльність.
І що на тлі цього всього утворюється Православна церква України - єдина помісна церква.
Власне, те, чого ми і прагнули.
Тому, якось дещо дивно виглядає позиція багатьох представників духовенства і мирян.
Це викликає подив і нерозуміння.
На службі тут згадують спершу владику Епіфанія, потім патріарха Філарета.
Хоча патріаршого титулу у нього вже фактично немає.
Адже від грудня 2018 року, коли відбувся об’єднавчий собор
і було ухвалено рішення про ліквідацію Київського патріархату,
митрополит Філарет втратив звання патріарха Київського і всієї Руси-України.
Тим не менше Філарета шанують у церковних колах,
адже він дуже багато зробив для розбудови української православної церкви
і для надання їй томоса.
Але нещодавні заклики Філарета про відновлення Київського патріархату
священнослужителі цього храму сприймають з тривогою.
І підтримувати у цьому свого колишнього предстоятеля не будуть.
Київський патріархат був ліквідований, і ми є складовою Православної церкви України.
Ми належимо до Київської міської єпархії ПЦУ.
Нечисленні віряни, які приходять у будні на службу до храму, про конфлікт чули.
Для них важливо, аби він не потягнув за собою серйозніші наслідки -
втрату довіри до єдиної Православної церкви України.
Ми по всім церквам раніше ходили, не знали, як і що.
А зараз приходимо і знаємо, що це наша Українська церква, в яку ми віримо, і я сподіваюся, що так і буде.
Віряни, яких зустріли біля єдиного патріаршого храму митрополита Філарета -
Володимирського кафедрального собору -
вважають, що причина конфлікту - особисті амбіції двох церковних лідерів.
Це я вважаю не конфлікт, це якісь політичні ігри на фоні якихось недомовленостей, різних поглядів.
Трохи політика в цьому замішана, трохи зміна президента.
Я за українську помісну церкву.
А чи це буде Київський патріархат, чи автокефальна церква, чи московська… Хоча московська - ні…
90-річному митрополиту Філарету важко розпрощатися з минулим,
вважають церковні експерти.
Адже усе своє життя той перебував на керівних посадах у церкві,
а тепер, фактично, усунутий від керування і розбудови ПЦУ.
Хоча як заявляв Філарет, згідно з усними домовленостями між ним та Епіфанієм,
планував стати головуючим у церковному уряді - синоді.
Уже сам факт, що такі приховані бесіди велися,
обурює інших митрополитів, які брали участь у об’єднавчому соборі.
Про ці домовленості ніхто не говорив ні мені, як представнику Московського патріархату,
який приймав участь у соборі, ні автокефальним єпископам, які також брали участь.
І тоді говорити про нашу участь було би складно, оскільки ми йшли не до Філарета,
не до Київського патріархату, реанімацією якого хоче нині Філарет, ми йшли до об'єднання,
до помісної церкви, на заклик патраха Варфоломія.
Конфлікт, який переріс у публічну площину, на думку деяких експертів,
може призвести до того, що на наступному засіданні синоду,
який відбудеться наприкінці травня,
єпископи можуть проголосувати за так званні штрафні санкції щодо Філарета.
Йдеться, наприклад, про заборону використовувати патріарший куколь,
печатки і бланки вже ліквідованого Київського патріархату.
Можливо, буде спроба повторного відсунення патріарха Філарета
від влади і намагання відправити його на спокій.
Можливо, буде апеляція до Вселенського патріарха, все буде зроблено чужими руками,
коли Вселенський патріарх буде накладати санкції, хоча за статутом це має зробити священний синод.
Тим не менше релігійні експерти вважають,
що суперечка не призведе до розколу ПЦУ та втрати томоса.
Кажуть, це не вигідно ані Києву, ані Константинополю,
який, надавши автокефалію Україні, вступив у конфлікт з Російською православною церквою.
Не бачать вони і підтримки Філарета серед єпископату.
Показовим було те, що на запрошення почесного патріарха Філарета
на святкування на честь священномученика Макарія відреагували лише чотири єпископи.